jours c'est une fois quitte l'airé là et
c'est foutu et c'est en ce moment
justement en temps de paix il faut
prévenir les hitler et que hitler a été
aussi monté par toute l'industrie
européenne dont l'industrie française
mais le temps du tout facile de le lui
donner de l'argent à laurent apprécié
par ailleurs justement jean michel royer
de tout temps il est pacifiste de tout
temps eu des pacifistes justement et me
dit carl à lui et feuilleter cet album
de l'assiette au beurre que nous avons
publié chez nietzsche et son éditeur de
jean paul simmons king qui rappelle un
antimilitarisme son hôtel vous vous
raccrochez je crois qu'ils aient la
tradition socialiste révolutionnaire
anarchiste puisque cette antimilitarisme
là c'était celui que l'école émancipée
par exemple et que les syndicats
d'instituteurs anarchisant aux
socialistes révolutionnaires ont
pratiqué notamment pendant pendant toute
la guerre et qui reste d'ailleurs à
celle actuelle en effet mes parents
étaient instituteurs aussi mon père et
ma mère est intéressante et 8h c'est
qu'il avait bien sûr c'est pour ça que
j'ai ce tribun bouchons ce que j'ai
appris que j'étais tout enfant c'est ce
que vous dites c'est cette haine de la
guerre pendant l'entre-deux-guerres on a
pensé on a passé son temps à maudire le
fascisme ou qu'ils constituent et puis
on arrivait toujours 40
je suis bien d'accord il ce que disait
cabu il faut empêcher les hitler
d'exister c'est un problème dispose en
temps de paix bien entendu passante très
facile à partir du moment où ils sont là
on est coincé et oui on nous désigne
toujours un ennemi mais là je leur ai
demandé au capitaine justement la marque
celui-ci vous aviez l'impression en
indochine de défendre la patrie est ce
qu'il y avait
agression aux frontières de la france
vous étiez à dix mille kilomètres de la
france je ne comprends pas ce que vous
faisiez un ado chine d'abord mais si
jamais je n'ai pas été en m2 chine
n'avait pas l'âge oui c'est un roman
c'est un roman c'est un roman mais vous
savez les romands sont parfois plus
important ou plus facile à utiliser pour
défendre un point de vue que les livres
d'histoire j'ai fait un livre d'histoire
qu'il a peut-être plus à madame carle
car c'était un livre dédié
je ne crois avoir lors de la dédicace la
vente a dédié un garçon de 21 ans était
mort pour la france mais c'était un
jeune communiste et qui en mourant avant
de mourir vais laisser un petit mot à ça
si tu as un petit ne baisse pas la tête
parce que ton papa a été fait l'idée est
naturellement dans ce livre qui a été
prise à une ligne de gauche on m'a
catalogué homme de gauche attendent le
chien et livre dirais comme de droite ne
serait que pour moi ça n'est pas perdre
et il ya quand même eu ni j'aimerais
quand même raconté résumé voilà votre
ouvrage c'est intéressant et je pense
que pour emilie cayre je n'ai pas eu le
temps de le faire parvenir ce jour les
mecs vous lisiez mais si j'ai bien tout
compris il s'agit d'un capitaine qui a
choisi de les nourrir dien bien phu et
qui entraîne avec lui une dizaine de
garçons qui ont environ 18 ans il les
entraîne pour aller mourir avec lui à
dien bien phu c'est parce que mère de
famille comme a été mêlé karl peut
penser de ce que je peux vous coupez
monsieur monsieur fabio pour dire que
même je vois un peu différemment le sol
effectivement sous les traits d'un
capitaine qui repoussait par le
commandement car je voudrais que vous
sépariez le monde des capitaines de
celui des généraux et même dès que la
danse est subtil distinguo excusez mon
sac et il y en a d'autres qui profitent
de l'activité des noms qui parfois donc
assez les plus sensibles
les militants comme effectivement on lui
refuse d'aller rejoindre ses camarades
il entraîne avec lui des garçons 18 ans
en leur proposant de se dépasser
car je crois vous voulez ce qui est
important dans la nuit c'est beaucoup
plus que les grandes notions d'armé et
même de patrie bien que je tienne c'est
l'amitié
est ce le dépassement de soi même la vie
est faite de l'humanité dans tout le
mandat
on a une batterie batterie même vous
allez madame quand on est dans la vie
professionnelle quand nous sommes à
paris de la haute cour dans une vie que
j'ai connu avec que ceux qui m'entourent
là où nous sommes agressés tous les
jours par la civilisation qui n'est pas
seulement pétrolière de jordi vous
apercevez évident que non seulement il
ya très peu d'amis qui sont prêts à
donner leur vie pour vous et que même
pour 100 francs ou 1000 francs ses
dépendances
en voulant relève one et qu'on est
capable de faire des contorsions
extraordinaire la différence avec
l'armée ce vin et et le cynisme il en a
charmé et moi je vous donne le sentiment
du petit garçon de j'étais dans le
sillage des dangers j'ai découvert
tamini tyrannie la neige pour la
première fois j'ai mangé mais ma fin de
ma vie mais j'ai aussi et j'ai aussi
découvert des garçons que je n'aurais
jamais rencontré et ce n'était pas l'un
d'eux s'était uni est normal dans le sud
de la france bon mais où didier
méditerranée mais c'est pas vrai moi
j'ai fait mon service militaire je suis
et dont j'ai fait la dauge effet
l'algérie j'ai peur j'ai trouvé j'ai
trouvé aucune camaraderie sinon la
camaraderie que donne là que procure la
boisson la phallocratie tous tous les
excès tous les vices humains sont
révélés et sont d'ailleurs si vous
voulez développer dans ces cases dans
lesquelles gérard défendirent que à la
caserne vous allez trouver une amitié
vous allez trouver des gens qui
pensaient comme vous et qui est qui qui
qui quêtent c'est ça l'amitié comme ça
mais je vais aller encore plus loin que
vous attendez si vous voulez on va se la
voir mais dans notre parution du livre à
travers ses dessins
on les a vus déjà ils sont passés en
même temps excusez-moi vrille et j'ai
pas là il prévu le retour on avait
demandé alors pour les vins
d'hautvillers dans le sens de parler
c'est à dire un contrechamp j'effectue
absolument je n'ai pas suivi donc est ce
qu'on a vu les vôtres jamie se sont pas
mieux des soldes ce que vous on n'a plus
vu les investisseurs alors je pense
qu'on va pouvoir voir les dessins de
l'assiette au beurre ce qui nous
permettra ensuite de demander à emilie
karl de nous dire si c'est l'armée qui a
connu la relaxe elle n'a pas été avec
laser mais cette armée que vous avez
vous nous présenter dans l'assiette au
beurre salé revêt ce que nous voyons là
c'est dans les colonies à l'unisson
jaune de meneur larnaudie dans les
talons des scènes de répression les
textes je ne développe pas elle c'est
bien ça c'est des vocations sur 1905
c'est l'évocation des massacres en
russie vous savez que c'était le début
officiel potemkine
alors là un dessin extrêmement dur très
violent sur la patrie qui est un dessin
dosso qui était un trek temps ça c'est
votre tribunal militaire
c'est peut-être la période de la sphère
dreyfus et je ne sais pas qui est je
crois que c'est lol le cha encore que
l'on aperçoit ici ça c'est un des héros
de la période 19 sens aimé colonel
marchand le héros de fachoda qui est
particulièrement maltraitées par
l'assiette au beurre ça c'est un dessin
dont on va voir la légende
officier de carrière qui dit ça c'est un
dessin superbe de jacques vision qui est
devenu ensuite les plus grands peintres
abstraits était très anti militariste
également là je ne vois pas très bien on
ne peut souhaiter aux doors roosvelt je
crois qui était le président des états
unis
ça c'est une scène d'exécution pendant
je ne sais pas une expédition coloniale
là c'est un officier de carrière
caricaturer qui dira aux civils
mais qui dit aux soldats qui vont parce
qu'ils l'ont quitté l'armée ne pensez
pas que quand vous serez devenu dessine
où nous serait supérieur j'aurais déjà
vous dire une chose royer c'est que vous
parlez de ses dessins à cette odeur mais
à l'avs les peuples de ces dessins ou à
peu près il y avait d'autres instituts
terme a permis aux cards
il y avait par exemple car vous faites
allusion dans votre livre à la chèvre
qui broutent la chèvre de monsieur
seguin d'alphonse daudet il y avait
d'autres d'instituteurs comme monsieur
hamel les comptes du lundi 9 h laudes et
vous rappeler monsieur hamel cet
instituteur le jour où les allemands
arrivent et vont imposer qu'on apprenne
plus que l'allemand à l'école il fait sa
dernière kleiner club
c'est la dernière classe il est ému
comme il ne peut plus rien dire il écrit
à la craie vive la france
allez vous-en mes enfants la chasse est
terminée et je pense tout de même
soulevé plus ou si vous voulez vous
continuer à brouter quelque peu cher
romain montagne il faut qu'il y ait
encore des hommes qui s'occupent de
défendre non seulement les bergers
malheureusement ces sommes ne sont pas
là pour parler à ma place car ils sont
presque tous morts car l'armée s'est
essentiellement quelque chose qui sait
quand on en a besoin et je rejoindrai le
point du cas du plupart des casernes
c'est moche c'est mieux aujourd'hui mais
c'est très moche mais il faut jamais
juger vous n'allez pas juger un système
social par le sourire des employés de la
sécurité sociale en mai j'entends tout à
fait là les institutions en place dans
les dix
c'est over est toujours très bien le
militaire bientôt ils siègeront avec une
fleur dans les cheveux mais il y aura
toujours au bout le poteau d'exécution
je veux dire tout à l'heure on va voir
un une séquence sur l'alarmé on devait
l'avoir mais on a été obligés de
supprimer parce que nous sommes trop
longue j'aurais bien aimé vous montrer
cette armée qui est très particulier en
ce sens que les militaires ont le
cheveux longs ne sais pas et que
lorsqu'on leur fait quelques remarques
lorsque leurs supérieurs leur disent ils
dans des deux est salie si vous ne
pourrez pas sortir il en réfère à leur
syndicat parce qu'ils sont syndiqués ils
sont payés au smig ou peut-être un peu
plus maintenant c'est une armée très
particulière j'aurais aimé justement
vous réagissiez sur ce reportage mais
hélas nous n'avons pas le temps que j'ai
passé se rapproche des autres offres
nous est ce qui me frappe c'est par
rapport à l'assiette au beurre tout de
même l'armée aujourd'hui a beaucoup
changé
bien sûr il ya des tas de choses à
changer il ya beaucoup de points sur
lesquels on peut encore elle reste
d'ailleurs l'union de la gauche
d'accord avec le rpr propose six mois
service militaire on puisqu'ils sont
majoritaires très largement à
l'assemblée retouché passing votre
ensemble il y aura le moins qui peut
être quelque chose qui changera dans ce
domaine là mais ce qu'il faut dire aussi
c'est que être objecteurs de conscience
au début du siècle par exemple si vous
conduisez abitibi et et dessins de
l'assiette au beurre qui était le bras
militaire c'était à droite qu'est ce qui
a changé dans l'intervalle ce qui a
changé il ya eu des militants
syndicalistes élus des militants qui se
sont battus qui ont fait la grève de la
faim voulait évoquer dans votre main
dans votre livre on a eu un seul statut
des objecteurs de conscience c'est
peut-être très suffisant il ya encore
des objecteurs de conscience et encore
des procès et cabu dont on parle
beaucoup mais tout de même ça a bougé
quand vous avez une armada
deux bombes atomiques qui élimine la
pietà il
l'infanterie donc ils peuvent se
permettre de donner une corde un peu
plus longues à la laisse mais il ya
toujours ce système ce système c'est le
pouvoir sait c'est l'instrument du
pouvoir l'armée vous avez vos fermiers
je suis pas du tout du tout allez vous
connaissez le coin oui le point celui je
fais aujourd'hui madame et les le dessin
est très grand mais j'aimerais mieux
parler de votre mari car je suppose
madame que jean karl était un homme
donnant et vous même dit que lorsque
pendant la fin de l'occupation
votre mari était dans le maquis un jour
un jeune prenait la garder votre mac kee
votre mari pardon antimilitariste
libertaire et il faut savoir ceci
liberté à libertaire ça veut dire celui
sur six en fait toutes contraintes
sociales et politiques
la batterie - votre mari s'est proposé
pour prendre les gardes et on le dit
comment une fois excusez moi
j'interprète toi un pacifiste prendre un
fusil il a donc compris qu'à un moment
c'est le contraire sinon ma vie gatinois
par ses fils je ne prends pas la tête je
n'admet pas qu'un jeune la prenne à ma
place la vie d'un gène vaut mieux que la
mienne voilà mais il s'est quand même
proposé pour prendre la relève du jeune
doux alors je me suis mal exprimé
alors peut-être parce que monsieur parce
que les gens meurent avec des soldats de
la garde à sa place il a déjà mais la
vie je n'accepte pas sages ces
pacifistes jeune fille non pas seulement
pour moi mais pour les autres je dirais
même que je peux promettre un jeune à ma
place c'est ce que j'ai cru lire aussi
je n'ai pas tous les jours je me suis
mal les pages en mémoire d'un enfant
c'est ce que j'ai cru dire c'est qu'on
dirait effectivement il
là aussi michèle berthy quand vous
voulez non c'est pas michel meurtre et
j'aimerais bien vous posiez une autre
question mais dans mon conducteur
j'avais michèle berthy qu'il fait
chanter
rené fallet venez avec nous alors on
n'est pas les venez avec nous prenez une
chaise
vous êtes un invité défilé karl non pour
nous tourner le dos là venez donc avec
nous tenait entre qu'un but et moir
entre cabu et moi vous savez que c'est
une mauvaise fréquentation n'est fallait
déboîtement d'accord